Continental Tire Coach's Corner good
morning coach how are you good morning
Dan how's everything going don't okay we
were just wondering if you didn't go to
Cal out of high school where would you
have gone Kansas how close was it to go
into Kansas I was between it was between
Cal and Kansas those were two last
schools when my dad's family being from
from that area
those were the two schools I had Larry
Brown he was he came in he was aiming
campanelle with all the two coaches to
come into the house so it was between
those two didn't you beat Kansas your
freshman year
no no no we lost to them in the sweet 16
after beating Duke in the tournament
they were the next opponent and we came
up a little short
I thought you played that did you play
them in the regular season we did we
played them in at their place we lost
him twice in the tournament and then in
my sophomore year we went to Kansas and
played them there and we came up short
again would you have been a one and done
one and done no I think no I will
probably if I if I went to Kansas I
probably had to stay another year stay
three years because they had some
talented point guards I think Adonis
Jordan was there so as a freshman I
probably had to come off the bench you
wouldn't have started in Kansas I don't
think so that's a great question well
well that's why you didn't go to Kansas
Jason what about could you played out of
high school in the NBA maybe that's a
yeah that's a humble yes right no yeah
you know because I got to play with with
the with the the pros very early you
know in high school so the fear factor
wasn't there because I you know play too
close against Chris Mullin Tim Hardaway
you know Marshall onus Gary Payton be
Shaw you know those guys on on a daily
basis in the summertime so maybe in high
school you're going against these guys
yeah I was lucky you know Don Nelson
invited me
over to play against you know those guys
at Golden State you know mitchrichman
Run TMC when you had Mullin and Tim
Hardaway you know being able to play
against those guys while they practice
you know that was that was a lot of fun
it was a great experience
did you see you played against Gary
Payton as well well I got the I grew up
under him so yes I you know I got to
play against him to be Shaw Antonio
Davis Greg foster you know sorry I got
to play against those guys why they were
you know on their way to the NBA or in
the NBA you know at a high school did
Payton trash talk to you or was he more
of a mentor here's a couple of questions
we had from the other day if I said you
start your team and playing with today's
NBA you can start with Shaq or Kobe who
you starting your team with oh man you
know SEC SEC SEC could have done a lot
more than he was probably I don't want
to say you know left to do because he
can handle he you know oh good question
I'm I'm gonna go with gold Kobe what's
your favorite Kobe story favorite Colby
story I guess coming back from an injury
when I had the blonde hair and I had I
ended up guarding him down the stretch
and he went to jump for that for the
game-winner on a jump shot I want to
jump I was already down and he was still
up and you know how the story goes he
makes it do you think the blonde hair
like help me down let me get off the
ground I here's the other question I'll
give you Shaq and Kobe or Jordan and
Pippen we have a lot of time we have a
lot of time on our hands Jason I'm see
that I'm gonna go with MJ and Scottie
yeah yeah I don't think there's a wrong
answer
but no there but I think Jordans always
the right answer I think you can use if
you're the
either of those teams you go to sleep
very well each night you don't have to
worry okay we'd love to compare we love
you know it's like Lonzo ball was gonna
be the next Jason Kidd now the Greek
freaks the next LeBron so who's closer
is is Lonzo closer to being the next
Jason Kidd or the Greek freak the next
LeBron I would say the Greek freak to
LeBron what do you see with his game you
know the development of it and and
what's left in your role as coach of
Greek freak well I think just he's a
sponge where he can absorb you know
what's being said to him and then being
able to translate that you know taking
that out onto the court and I think also
you know he's shown a lot of you know
patience you've heard the stories of you
know not letting him shoot the three
when we got here and entrusting us with
that to help him you know develop
something that he could have you know
that he can rely on and as you can see
when he has the ball he's as good as
anyone in the open court
and also when he has the ball in the
paint he's one of the best finishers but
it's just something that he trusted and
when he trusts someone you know he he
does all the work and you could see that
it's a lot of fun to watch LeBron talked
to you during the game we just talked
real briefly at the start I just wished
him good luck but that's a very
Christmas so he didn't say anything
during a game no he was talking he was
shooting the ball extremely well and he
let us know wait how does he do that so
when he releases it does he turn to the
bench and say something oh no he doesn't
have to turn to the bench he after he
releases it and you can it goes in he he
just he can let you know nicely you
shooting the ball at a high level you
became a dangerous shooter later in your
career did you change your shot because
and the reason why I bring this up is I
think you're on record is saying Lonzo
needs to change his shot did you change
your shot later in your career yeah I
did change my shot you know coming in
the league I didn't shoot the ball
extremely well my focus wasn't to shoot
it it was to define the open guy or try
to score it shooting was not something
that I worked on early in my career but
as I got older the technique and what I
needed to do to become a better shooter
and also to extend my career was
something that I worked on when I was in
New Jersey but your form you at least
had form to work with yeah but
everybody's different you know I you
know I thought there was a comparison of
Kevin Martin and involved in the way
that they shoot the ball not saying that
it's the exact but it's like a golf
swing everybody's you know has a
different golf swing you know Jim Furyk
has a different cost when compared to
Tiger Woods but it's about the impact
right with the swing if they get back to
square square one but for the jump shot
yeah I think it just he has to he's
gonna have to fix it at some point well
it's I know what you're saying with the
golf swing but nobody's trying to block
your golf swing and in his right you
know he's got create room if he doesn't
create room going going right it's hard
for him to shoot it explain this to me
as I watch James Harden I don't know
what he does well athletically like he
doesn't jump out of the gym he's not the
quickest guy he's not the fastest guy
but it feels like whenever he wants to
score he can score explain yeah I just
saw that up close recently he is very
talented it's amazing you know he I
think people don't understand how big he
really is you know you sometimes think
he is you know 6-4 6-3 but he's not he
is he's a big guy who could handle the
ball as as a rhythm to it and knows how
to get to his spots he's he's like to
nobley you know knows how you know he
knows left-handed and wants to get to
his left hand
Hey and he's gonna get to his left hand
and there's nothing you can do about it
and then I think just his tempo he's
never in a rush
anything again I think he's a student of
the game he knows how to draw fouls he
knows how to put pressure on the defense
and the officials you faced him what
last Saturday yeah do you feel sorry for
the guy on your team who's got a
Guardium I feel I don't feel sorry I
should I've been in that position and no
one felt sorry for me but I think it's
it's just a challenge you know when you
go against the best you you want to try
to slow him down you're not gonna stop
them where's the guy you guarded and you
just you just went I got no chance here
but nobody's gonna feel sorry for me
well I mean Kobe and and you know the
likes of I had my rookie year I got to
guard Michael that no one felt sorry
morning you know what big numbers on you
I think yes they probably did Michael
probably could have put up bigger
numbers I think he just he might have
felt sorry and you probably don't want
to say a word to Jordan oh no no no
words right Jordan what can I get for
you mr. Jordan we'll get you a towel as
I was going out I'll get you the towel
no you don't want to say anything but
you want to compete and you do want to
you know try to slow him down but look
there there's special for reason and you
know Allen Iverson there's another guy
extremely fast and crafty and knows how
to score the ball and you knew he's
shooting the ball so that's what made
even worse I don't know if you saw the
news Lavar ball talking about maybe kids
coming out of high school and maybe you
could develop sort of an AAU type league
for one year instead of going to college
what do you think of that possibility
well I think one we gotta get more
coaches better teachers in a you circuit
because I think a lot of the kids are
missing the fact of the fundamentals
and we're at the highest level trying to
teach the fundamentals of the game
instead of just teaching the Exynos and
so I think we have to start recruiting
better teachers and coaches to help our
youth and in the sport of basketball
yeah there's some bad habits out there
plus you're getting an unfinished
product and you're teaching them things
that should have been taught years prior
yes they're missing a lot and so when at
this level when you're being judged on
wins and losses and you and came and get
to that point of you know protecting
yourself about where the loss is because
you're spending more time trying to
teach the fundamental of the game it you
know the unfinished product is not
finished until it's 23 24 years old and
a lot of the coaches at this level won't
be able to see that to the end I got you
Jordan had 36 on you you're your rookie
you had a triple-double though you're
your second year against him no no not
your alcohol yeah oh I got 25 15 and 11
you torched Jordan you own Jordan in
that game but I got him 36 your first
meeting with Jordan you could have just
say it was my first year at it you know
I'm all about accuracy
you know what broadcast is the way I
shoot my jumper it's about accuracy
Jason you know that oh I know I know you
bring it up Dellavedova
I would take a piece out of Dellavedova
just letting you know they they call me
the Irish freak just to let you know
just the own Jordan the second year
though that's cool hey basically feel
good going to practice today yeah but
you should get this box score and just
put it on and like yes let your kids you
know your players look at it go no coach
you put up a triple-double on on Mike
you dropped the mic you know what's
funny is uh
we're running into era of people not
knowing who MJ is so
I would have to put a picture up there
with next oh that's not true
if it wasn't for his shoe they would not
know who William Tell yes oh my gosh all
they need to do is look down to know who
Michael Jordan is shoes good luck this
season always great to catch up with you
Jason thank you thank you
you too that's Jason Kidd yeah brought
up the jumper again but I waited a while
I know I've waited a while ducked out of
a shooting contest with me he's sick out
of a shooting contest when he was with
the Mavs unbelievable Continental Tire
coaches corner from Sunday rain to snow
and everything in between continental
tires engineer to tire for what you do
extraordinary performance and
reliability putting confidence into
driving for more information in the
location of a dealer near you visit
Continental Tire calm come home tire for
what you do for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]